in order to actually solve the refugee
crisis you have to solve the problems
from which the refugees are fleeing
these are very specific areas the Syria
Eritrea Ethiopia I mean that's where
almost all of them are coming from and
that's because all those places are in
the long-term grip of very violence a
dangerous civil wars it just makes very
very urgent the need for negotiated
settlements in in all these parts of the
world I'm glad that it's begun to be
called the refugee crisis for a while
people referring to these folks as
migrants and that's not exactly what
they are I mean they're really there
really people running for their lives
and I have conquered of course I think
they need to be not left to starve and
die in various no man's land you know
they do need to be accommodated somehow
I do think that there is a danger of
infiltration of you know as it were
terrorist fighters infiltrating as part
of the refugee movement you know the
refugee ave the refugees are really
refugees but but it wouldn't you know
it's not rocket science to understand
that it's perfectly possible to place
some jihadist fighters in there you know
and and i think i'm sure that security
forces around europe extremely aware of
that and very concerned about it and
that complicates the political decisions
or the humanitarian decisions I just
think it's got to be faced you know you
obviously need to stop people dying but
you also need to prevent terrorists from
coming into the country and killing
other people so so I mean it's a very
very difficult subject but as I say the
solution has to be to look at the causes
or the refugees are in effect you know
you need to look at the cause in order
to remove the effect
you